now that we know how a signal can spread
through a neuron through an electro
tonic potential and action potentials
and combinations of the two let's put it
all together by looking again at the
structure of a neuron and anatomy of a
neuron and thinking about why it has
that Anatomy and how it all can work so
we've already talked about the dendrites
as being where the neuron can be can be
stimulated from multiple inputs if we're
in the brain this might be these
dendrites might be near the terminal
ends of axons of other neurons if we're
some type of sensory cell this kind of
these dendrites could be stimulated by
some type of sensory input but let's
just say for the sake of argument they
are stimulated in some way and because
they're stimulated in some way it allows
it allows positive ions to flood in it
allows positive ions to flood in to the
neuron from the outside as we know
there's a potential difference it's more
negative in the neuron from the inside
of the neuron than outside of the neuron
and so if a channel gets opened up
because of some stimulus that would
allow positive ions that would allow
positive ions to flow in and the primary
positive ions we've been talking about
are the sodium ions maybe this is some
type of of sodium gate that gets opened
up because of this stimulus so when that
happens you will have electrotonic
spread you will have an electro electro
tonic potential being spread so let's
say that we had a voltmeter right here
on the axon hillock it's kind of the
hill that leads to the axon right over
here so what you might see happening
after some amount of time so let me draw
so let's say this is our voltage in
millivolts across the membrane our
voltage difference I should say this is
a passage of time let's say the stimulus
happens at time zero but right at time
zero we haven't really noticed it with
our voltmeter our voltage right across
the membrane right over there is that
that equilibrium negative 70 millivolts
but after some small amount of time this
electrotonic potential has gotten to
this point because all of these positive
charges are trying to get away
from each other it's gotten to that
point and you might see you might see a
you might see a bump in the voltage the
in the voltage difference I guess I
should say this thing might go up so it
might look something like that now that
by itself might not be we might not have
gotten the voltage difference low enough
I guess we could say or we might not
have gotten the the voltage inside of
the member inside the cell posit enough
in order to trigger the voltage gated
ion channels and so maybe nothing
happens maybe maybe this right over here
this is negative 55 millivolts and so
that's what you have to get the voltage
up to the voltage difference up to in
order to trigger the in order to trigger
the ion channels the ion channels right
over there so those are the sodium
channels to get positive charge in
here's the potassium channels to get the
positive charge out the axon hillock has
a ton of these because these are really
there once they get triggered they can
trigger an impulse that can then go down
the entire axon and maybe stimulate
other things maybe in the brain or where
else or whatever else this neuron might
be connected to so maybe that's stimulus
by itself didn't trigger it but let's
say that there's another stimulus that
happens right at the same time or around
the same time and that happens and on
its own that might have caused a similar
type of that might have caused a similar
type of bump right over here but when
you add the two together and they're
happening at the same time their
combined bumps their combined bumps are
enough to trigger an action potential in
the hillock or series of action
potentials in the hillock and so then
you really have essentially fired the
neuron so now all sorts of positive
charge gets flushed in flushed into the
neuron and then purely through
electrotonic spread you will have you
will have this electrotonic potential
spread down the axon
now this is the interesting part because
we could think a little bit about what
is the best way for an axon to be
designed in general if you're trying to
transfer current the ideal thing to do
is the thing that your transfer
during the current down should conduct
really well and you could or you could
say it has low resistance low resistance
but you want it to be surrounded by an
insulator you want it to be surrounded
so this was a cross-section you want it
to be surrounded by an insulator that
has high resistance high resistance and
the reason is is because the reason is
is because you don't want the electric
you don't want the potential to you
don't want the the the potential to leak
across across your across your membrane
high high resistance right over here if
you didn't have something high
resistance around it then your signal
will actually transfer will actually go
your current would actually go slower
this is true if you're just dealing with
electronics if you just had a bunch of
copper wires on one side and you had
some copper wires that were surrounded
by a really good insulator a really good
resistor for example plastic or rubber
of some kind the current is actually
going to have less energy loss less
energy loss it's going to travel faster
when it's surrounded by an insulator so
you might say okay well gee the best
thing to do would be to surround this
entire axon with a good insulator and
for the most part that is true it is
surrounded by a good insulator that is
what the myelin sheath is so let's say
we wanted to surround this whole thing
with just one big one big grouping of
Schwann cells so one big myelin sheath
which is a good insulator does not
conduct current well so this right over
here is just one big myelin myelin
sheath one big myelin sheath right over
here now what's the problem with this
well if this axon is really long and
let's say you know you're a dinosaur or
something and you're you're just trying
to go up your neck and your neck is 20
feet long or even a human being where
you know we're reasonable size and
you're going several feet or even well
well whatever you're going to want to go
a reasonable distance purely with
electrotonic with electrotonic spread
your signal remember it dissipates your
signal is going to be really weak
right over here you're going to have a
week you're going to have a weak signal
on the other end it might not be even
strong enough to make anything
interesting happening at these terminals
which wouldn't be strong enough to make
to trigger maybe other neurons or
whatever else might needs to happen at
this other end so that you say okay well
then why don't we try to boost the
signal well how would you boost the
signal we say okay I like having this
myelin sheath but why don't we put gaps
in the myelin sheath every so often and
then those gaps would allow the membrane
to interface with the outside and in
those areas we could put some voltage
gated child channels that can release
action potentials when to in order to
essentially boost the signal and that's
is exactly what the anatomy of a typical
neuron is like so instead of just one
big insulating sheath like this it would
let me make some gaps here whoops I
wanted to do that in black so actually
let me just draw it like this let me
just erase this so clear and let me
clear this that's good enough and so
what we could do is we could put gaps we
could put gaps in it right over here
where the axon the external membrane
itself can can interface with its
surroundings and of course we know we
call those gaps the nodes of ranvier or
Ranvir and i'm not really sure how to
pronounce it so let me put those gaps in
here so you put those gaps in here so
these are the myelin sheath and this
right over here is a node of ranvier a
node I'll just these are nodes of
ranvier or NVA and right in those little
nodes right in those nodes right where
the myelin sheath isn't we can put these
voltage-gated channels we could put
these voltage-gated channels to
essentially boost a signal if we if the
signal have to go electro tonically all
the way over here to be very weak it's
going to dissipate as it goes down but
it could be just strong enough right at
this point in order to trigger these
voltage-gated channels
in order to essentially boost the signal
again in order to trigger an action
potential boost the signal and now the
signal is boosted a little dissipate
dissipate dissipate boost and a little
boost right over here again and then
it'll dissipate dissipate dissipate and
boost dissipate dissipate boost and so
by having this combination you want the
myelin sheath you want the insulator in
order to keep in order to keep the
transmission of the current to fast in
order to have minimal energy loss but
you do need these these areas where
where the myelin sheath isn't in order
to boost the signal in order for this in
order for the action potentials to get
triggered and so your signal can keep
being can look I guess keep being
amplified if we wanted to talk in kind
of electrical engineering speak and this
type of conduction where the signal just
keeps boosting and you know if you were
to just kind of superficially observe it
it looks like the signal is almost
jumping it's it's it gets triggered here
then gets triggered here then it gets
triggered here then it gets triggered
here and then it gets triggered here
this is called saltatory conduction
saltatory salta saltatory saltatory
conduction saltatory conduction it comes
from the latin word salt RA or salt I'm
once again I don't know how to pronounce
my Latin isn't too good but it comes
from the Latin word for salt re which
means to jump around or to hop around
and that's because it looks like the
signal is hopping around but that's not
exactly what's happening the signal is
traveling passively through it gets
triggered here in the axon hillock then
it then it travels passively through
electrotonic spread and then it gets
boosted and you have the myelin sheath
around it to make sure it goes as fast
as possible and you get very little loss
of signal and then it gets boosted at
the nodes of ranvier because it triggers
it triggers these voltage-gated channels
again that that triggers an action
potential and then your signal gets
boosted and then it dissipates boosted
dissipates boosted dissipates boosted
dissipates maybe it could even get
boosted again and then it can trigger
whatever else it has to trigger